tous
oh
et
le soir
et de la politique
c'est que du foot mais c'est plus que du
foot
la guerre c'est un mythe qui a tout
changé
j'ai descendu les champs elysées avec le
maillot de l'équipe de france je criais
tu te dis d'un président thierry
président visé qui fêtait black blanc et
peur
les maîtres chacun dans une case tous
les joueurs de l'équipe de france sans
exception souhaitent affirmer leur
opposition à la décision prise par la
fédération française de football
d'exclure nicolas anelka
ça s'est arrêté à acheter
que constater comme vous
de france où des caïds immatures
commandent à des gamins
et une fracture qui creusent et divisent
mais qu'il de france qui gagne c'est
blackburn
et puis une équipe de france qui perd
ses des racailles de cardio
l'équipe de france questionne la société
française sur ses obsessions
j'en avais assez des bandes de racailles
aura besoin débarrasser
prochaine à calais
black blanc beur ce qui nous faisait
rêver ce qui vous représentez sa cpt
c'est tombé par terre c'est cassant
vingt années de grâce
de désunion et d'espoir retrouvé
le foot est le miroir de la société
française
les joueurs n'ont plus le droit à
l'erreur
1996 2016 les bleus raconte une autre
histoire de france
quand on regarde l'équipe de france il y
a qu une couleur les bleus